it's like having tattoos in japan are
like
indicative of the yakuza right
supposedly even though it didn't start
with the yakuza it started with
firefighters what yeah
so when i interviewed the the ex yakuza
member he obviously we got onto the
topic of tattoos right because the guy's
[ __ ] covered in tats um and he told
me that originally
firefighters during the edo period would
get tattooed and i was like why
firefighters and it's like so that if
they die in a fire it's easy to identify
the body oh god and i'm like and it's
like they put that they put it in there
that took a [ __ ] time
and i'm like that took a [ __ ] dark
turn but then he put it into perspective
being like it's also just a matter of
like you having that tattoo back in the
older days that was an honor because
that just showed that was die undying
proof that you are doing a very
dangerous job to save other people's
lives and like and for some reason over
the course of time with the yakuza and
like how you'd get tattooed when you
enter jail and stuff like that you know
as a mark it just slowly turned into
like a negative connotation to the point
where now today any japanese person with
like a [ __ ] little tiny star tattoo
on the back of their palm is considered
a yakuza member yeah you know and it's
like it's just so and it's gone to the
point where like you can't enter
obviously hot springs it's like it's
like a common one but you can't even
enter like public pools you can't go to
some beaches
if you have tattoos my dream like i
mentioned was anytime fitness right yeah
yeah you can't go to juice the only sign
on the wall that is in english is dear
all international members not even like
they are all international members
please cover up any tattoos that you
might be showing and it's like and it's
weird because it's like you know think
about it logically just because you have
a tattoo it doesn't mean that person is
a [ __ ] psychopath or a yeah yeah but
it's that whole mental image of oh
they're such a bad person because they
put some [ __ ] ink in their body that
you know it's it's this weird
stipulation of
tattoo equals yakuza now yeah
which is so dumb especially when it
comes the one i don't understand is when
that same rule applies to foreigners
here
yeah that is kind of odd yeah and i'm
like
you do realize yakuza is like a japan
thing only right guys it says a lot
about japanese society
there's a lot of answers says
how the tables have turned it's because
we've we know what this episode's gonna
be five million times this is what i'm
saying when me the memes that aren't
funny become funnier the more you just
keep saying it yeah squid game
so he just laughed he just left
nah but like uh but be funny
well like the the yakuza guy was saying
that um it's uh
you're just laughing this good game
yeah the actually i was just saying that
he put into like really interesting i
mean i asked him like what do you think
about the whole like tattoo stigma and
he was like oh it's [ __ ] stupid yeah
like because the the whole point of a
yakuza tattoo is we we put in tattoos
not to show people but to conceal it
it's like a massive difference the
people who want to show tattoos that's
got nothing to do with [ __ ] youngster
yeah
isn't going to go around [ __ ] being
like check out my tats bro like they
don't do that
and until japanese people understand
that i don't think the stigma is ever
going to go away i'd like to think it's
starting to go away because young people
now in japan are getting tats and they
don't give a [ __ ]
what do you think the new generation of
japan are more open to the idea of like
you know foreigners and just you know
things like ideas like very much so i
mean japan has been americanized for
decades now almost centuries now and
yeah but like i feel it's only just
recently where they you know look at so
you know american celebrities and
singers with you know who are covered in
tats and they go
if they can do that maybe we can do that
too
who the [ __ ] knew that maybe just
because you have a [ __ ] justin bieber
tattoo it doesn't make you a yakuza
member yeah because like um most of our
exposure to like japanese society comes
from the older generation right because
they have all the power in government i
actually have no idea about what the
youths
in japan are like thinking and you know
how much of and i mean you you walk down
you know shinjuku or shibuya any time of
the day or night and you'll see young
people
covered in tattle all the time you know
japanese people come in tats all the
time i i know this is kind of off topic
but i remember like someone told me that
um
when uh avengers came out right and you
do press tours yeah apparently it was
really difficult for to for robert
downey jr to come here because he did a
criminal record in the u.s oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah it's just like
okay i i mean i get it but but like i
mean but it's not doing it now yeah it's
like all right it just kind of shows
that it's like there's no there's no
room for but i mean i think
other countries are similar as well if
you have a criminal record though yeah
but it's kind of like yeah but japan is
definitely the type of country where you
make one mistake you are dead to the
world oh yeah yeah and it's like it
doesn't matter how much it doesn't
matter how much you do to try and redeem
it or try and like change your image
that you're a better person you're a
fixed person now you make one mistake
you're [ __ ] but it's the one thing
that is really worrying is that like a
lot of the laws
and like punishment specifically sound
surrounding like
like creep crimes i'll say
like the crimes you know like being a
chee can or being a pervert or being
like taking pictures of uh people in
places
punishment have you seen how much how
little you have to pay yeah yeah some of
them are like 20 like 20 dollar fines
yeah yeah like 20
what's the point that's a saturday night
out with the boys
yeah
they're kidding me like they have so
many stalkers here because it's just so
bad you just face no repercussions for
like for like stalking someone this is
actually like it's actually like
because unfortunately in a lot of cases
in japan the
if it's not a phys if it's not physical
harm that is a result of the crime then
it's not even considered like they don't
take into consideration that you know
you can be mentally scarred for a crime
and that's still having real life
repercussions because they just think oh
but did he touch you did he stab you did
he hurt you in any way
you'll get over it it's like well no
because some people don't [ __ ] get
over it like it's pretty [ __ ]
traumatizing for some young women to get
you know creeped on getting their photos
taken most likely being leaked on the
internet without them knowing yeah and
then for the [ __ ] law system to turn
around and go yeah you'll get over it
because
nearly every single japanese woman i
spoke to had some horrible experience of
of someone being a pervert and like
nearly every japanese woman and nearly
pretty much every foreign woman as well
in japan yeah yeah has uh has had a
creepy experience i'm pretty sure sydney
has some as well yeah um
has definitely had some interest yeah
yeah yeah horrible it's it's actually
like terrifying and
i you know it's it's [ __ ] up and i
don't know how to change it because it's
not even like it's not even our country
to change you know yeah but you know i
think i mean it was so weird for me
hearing the first time i you know you go
to japan and if you buy a phone in japan
there is no silent option when you take
a picture if you if you buy a phone in
japan no matter what handset it is if
it's a japanese handset you cannot turn
off the sound
of the shutter when it takes a picture i
mean my phone is that
right
my phone's on silent right now
yeah that may just like that
yeah
in many ways you hear about that in
isolation you think well that's good you
know you're protecting people but it's
like what did it take for it to get to
that point yeah where we had to then
keep the shutter on like how rampant was
it and like you know the fact that japan
as far as i know is one of the only
countries on earth that has widespread
adoption of female-only cars
yeah
only during a certain time though right
right right like which you know which i
feel completely takes away the point of
a female-only car if you ask me because
it's like oh then i just have to avoid
these times
the women would welcome that but it's
like it's like
you know for it to be done to and had
have to be done says a lot yeah and you
know about society and uh i wouldn't
like me personally i wouldn't want to
raise a daughter in japan i i i would be
scared to death of like letting it go on
the train or something yeah well i think
the other problem as well is like
it's it's that a lot of the parents here
is not that i'm trying to tell japanese
parents how to be parents but like you
know considering i'm not one myself but
i think the problem is that a lot of the
parents also just don't teach their
daughters
what to do during those situations right
because they're like i feel like you you
ask any american parent or just western
parent you know like if their daughter
were to get into a horrible situation
like that to you know like teach them
some self-defense or you know like try
and defend themselves in any way that
they possibly can you know to
make a statement to be like i'm not
[ __ ] afraid of you yeah back off
right yeah in japan though they don't do
that no yeah because
there's no repercussions even if they
get caught yeah so they're just like if
i just ignore it then maybe it'll go
well but it doesn't if a guy is jacking
off to you on a train you punch him in
the face in japan
you're the [ __ ] because you're the
one who initiated physical violence
exactly right so in the eyes of the
police you're the one who initiated it
um yeah it's it's weird
like you can make the argument of oh
it's self-defense but then the law will
turn around and go well he wasn't
technically hurting you and oh and also
do you have proof that he was you know
yeah doing these acts yeah yeah it's
it's sad man it's really sad there is a
fundamental problem and just i don't
know like maybe they're trying to change
the law maybe they don't don't give a
[ __ ] i don't know but either way it's
messed up and it's more messed up that
again the parents are not teaching
i think there definitely needs to be
more protection for women here yeah it's
it's like it it is a thing women only
cars
is
minimum protection oh yeah exactly the
fact that we have to have min uh
women-only cars yeah
it's it's it shouldn't have gotten even
then it should be not solving that
that's not a solution
and yeah every pretty much every female
i've talked to has ha has had a story
you know has a story yeah there was a
there was a tv show i was watching and
it was like literally called like like
chican hunters or something
and it was literally like a show where
like four undercover cops would just go
on a train
and it was like this is just real
cameras and it was like gopro footage
but of course because it's interesting
so chris hanson japan yeah so but of
course in japan right so everything is
censored you literally cannot see
anything the whole because they're on a
train with a gopro because of japan they
don't like to show people on tv yeah you
can't see anything in this train yeah
they've blurred it out right but to
distinguish who the pervert isn't who
the victim is they're just blue blurs
and a pink blur
right and you can't see what's going on
yeah it's
absolutely i think it was maybe three
tokyo
gbs
tbs i don't know which channel it was i
only really watched like three i don't
watch nhk nhk is boring but it was like
first of all i was like this is terrible
production this is awful
but
they found like four dudes doing this in
like one day yeah in like the same like
car and it's like what the [ __ ]
and they would like they would have to
get camera footage of them doing it like
multiple times yeah so to prove that it
wasn't an accident because they could do
the whole bump and touch their ass but
they would have to like catch them
multiple times and then i don't know
what they did i i assume they just gave
them like a slap on the wrist or
something but they wouldn't show their
face or anything and uh it was just like
you wonder you're like well clearly like
this punishment isn't effective like if
you shamed them for doing it would it
help a little bit but it's also like is
it fair to ruin someone life over there
i don't know probably not but like it's
weird also there was like 20 cops for
like one dude touching a girl's ass tree
i was like i think you don't need this
many nopes i think one maybe two isn't
it i think i think i think two cops can
handle one one pervert i think i think
it's okay i know that you need like the
dude is not like nine feet tall and like
500 pounds i think i think one person
can handle it it's crazy right so they
have the four undercover detectives on
this train right they find the guy they
come out and then there's like eight
more police escorting this one guy
[ __ ] and it's like i
i get it like it's yeah you gotta arrest
him you want some backup i i totally
understand but like how much do you need
like come on like how much taxpayer
money is going towards that there's 12
dudes arresting them i mean there's
probably you know to some of those cops
it's like oh finally my first actual job
bro the fine doesn't even cover his walk
from the train to the [ __ ] train
holding room like the the police time
wasted doesn't even cover the fine they
gave this dude yeah it's a joke it's
[ __ ] stupid as [ __ ] it's like you
know i i'm sure if we went through uk
police or any uk laws or
australian laws i'm sure we could find
another ten thousand million things to
criticize about we're in japan and you
know there's what's what's on our mind
bro that was a that was a societal deep
conversation
this is what this episode did say a lot
about society
this one said a lot about how society is
kind of like squid game huh who knew
that one of the deepest uh trash taste
episodes to date started with
a shitty meme that makes no sense
says he says